I think it's fair to say that none of us
have ever seen a candidate like Donald J
Trump most remarkable is that Trump is
impervious or seemingly impervious to
any sort of fallout after he says things
that frankly if any other candidate said
anything like them they would be toast
last year the stalwarts of American
punter tree predicted over and over and
over again the Trump's candidacy would
unravel but it didn't don't take our
word for it take a listen they're
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
they're rapists and some I assume are
good people
Donald Trump isn't afraid to speak his
mind but this time it could cost him
most people think Trump is gonna flame
up or drop out he's gonna flame out very
very quickly Trump isn't paying the
price in the polls now Donald Trump is a
top contender for the presidential
Republican presidential nomination he's
a war hero because he was captured
I like people that weren't captured okay
I hate to tell you you have to ask
yourself has the Donald Trump stick
really run its course and today with
these comments about John McCain I very
well might have I don't think this is
the hand but I think and this may be a
little bit wishful thinking it might be
the beginning of the end I think this
was the beginning of the end for Donald
Trump really the beginning of the end of
Donald Trump I will eat my right hand if
Donald Trump is the Republican nominee
meanwhile here we go a new PPP poll
conducted after his remarks about McCain
still show him in first place with 19%
key there was blood coming out of her
eyes blood coming out of her wherever
red state organizers said this is the
beginning of the end
of trumps campaign I think this could be
the beginning of the end for Donald
Trump I think this is the beginning of
the end for Donald Trump two new polls
out today have Donald Trump in the lead
of the GOP pack even after his recent
controversial comments about Fox News
anchor megyn kelly Donald J Trump is
calling for a total and complete
shutdown of Muslims entering the United
States many people think that this
controversy could be the last straw
for Donald Trump I think this actually
is the beginning of the end and there is
new evidence today that Trump's recent
comments about Muslims aren't keeping
this popularity from rising Donald Trump
is not gonna be our president he will
probably flame out I would say we're
probably the next three to six bucks I
don't think we're gonna be talking about
Donald Trump in six months like a meteor
I do think he's gonna flame out Trump
will flame out I think he's a roman
candle that's a destined to burn out I
think Donald Trump is going to flame out
so every time people predict the demise
of Donald Trump he gets stronger every
time we try to predict that it's
happened we've been wrong I've done
predicting about that you always wonder
whether Trump's about to go over the
line there always seems to recover from
the delay that said the latest round of
nonsense was going to destroy his
candidacy just stop
we've been saying that for six months
stop you're gonna be wrong I was wrong I
thought Donald Trump is going to
self-destruction I'm doubling down on my
demise theory
I think he's gonna collapse I think he's
gonna be like sitting taking the Oval
Office and some January 1st he'll be
predicting a demise
on behalf of ourselves and our
colleagues we promise to better this
year